government guest today of course i
thought he was coming on the program to
talk about the government's asylum
seekers policy i promise i will get to
that of course um but really this
evening is dominated by that
registration of uh lord gait we're
joined now
by the home office minister tom purd's
glove to see if you can shed any light
on what happened um do we know why lord
gyt has decided to step down well sophie
i've been i have to say tour in the
television studios this evening talking
about the latest developments with
regard to rwanda so i haven't seen a
huge amount on this but of course lord
guy has a distinguished career in public
service in a number of roles i think
we're surprised as a government that
he's taken the decision that he hasn't
of course it'll be for him to set out in
more detail the reasons for why he's
reached the conclusion to resign that he
has but i'm sorry to see him go and um
and thank him for his service um you
know you're saying about how we're it's
a surprise for number 10 that that's
what we've been briefed as well
this resignation but at the same time
you know he did go in front of this
committee uh didn't he uh saying that
there was um he was frustrated with some
of the responses to partygate he's
previously said that there was
legitimate questions over whether the
prime minister uh broke um the
ministerial code after receiving this
fine over party gate it feels like he
felt his position was untenable
defending the prime minister doesn't it
i think lord guy would need to speak for
himself obviously it has been an
eventful few weeks that we've seen i
think the prime minister has been very
clear consistently that in terms of what
happened
with regard to gatherings in number 10
he's apologized unreservedly for that i
think we now need to move forward and
get on with the job of governing
certainly in my own constituency but
also when i go around the country and
campaigning in the bilateral for example
i've heard a lot of people saying that
they just want government to get on with
the job of governing they want the
opposition to talk about the issues that
matter as well i think that's where our
focus should now be but it's right that
lord guy sets those matters out in his
own terms in his own way in a way of his
choosing at the same time though it does
feel as though perhaps lord gait had
reached the end of his tether defending
boris johnson they've had run-ins before
haven't they uh over
the refurbishment of the downing street
flat when the prime minister failed to
disclose messages between himself and a
conservative peer who paid for the
renovations lord guide said that
demonstrated insufficient respect for
his role
the frustrations with boris johnson have
been well documented
i think that lord guy has been very
professional in his dealings in the work
that he's done and he's obviously
reached a conclusion that he wishes to
resign and that's what he's done and
it'll be for him to set out the reasons
why if that's what he wishes to do um i
i completely understand that um you
can't put words in his mouth we haven't
really got a statement yet from lord guy
explaining those reasons and so i
appreciate the position you're in
at the same time though lord guide is
the second person to have resigned from
this job under boris johnson's
premiership i mean he's only been prime
minister for three years sir alex allen
quit in 2020 after mr johnson refused to
accept his finding that home secretary
pretty patel had bullied civil servants
it doesn't look good does it to lose not
one but two ethics advisors
again i'm not going to get drawn on this
i've not had much opportunity to
familiarize myself with well we know we
know this happened we know you'll see
people have resigned from this frankly i
haven't got a sort of in-depth knowledge
of previous holders of the role and for
how long they've held the position for
um you know clearly there are term
lengths sometimes involved in public
appointments and people decide to serve
for a particular length of time there
may be personal reasons that is decided
not to continue i don't know and it
would be wrong for me to speculate um
finally some some people might be
looking at us thinking
it shouldn't be lord guy resigning over
this it should be boris johnson he's
been fired from by the police for
breaking the rules uh 148 of his own mps
has said that they've got no confidence
in him
and he's now lost two ethics advisors
i don't think the prime minister should
resign he was given an overwhelming
mandate in that 2019 general election he
delivered brexit he's got us through the
pandemic the vaccination rollout was a
huge success and the government played a
part in delivering that we're now
emerging from kovid 19 we're dealing
with a situation in ukraine we've got
the cost of living challenges and i work
with him on the illegal migration issue
week in week out and i know how
determined he is to get to grips with
that i think that for the prime minister
there is still a lot more to give and he
is committed to getting on with the day
job delivering on the promises that we
made and i know that's what he's
determined to do even if i will move on
to a real wonder but even if you lose
both of the by-elections coming up in
wakefield and tiverton he's the man for
the job by-elections are unpredictable i
mean i
obviously represent the corby
constituency we had a by-election in
2012 labour took the seat office i got
the seat back two and a half years later
having worked tirelessly for two years
campaigning and it just shows the
unpredictability that there is and
we've got two good very good candidates
who are working hard i hope that they're
going to be able to convince people in
those communities to vote for them and
vote conservative i'm backing them and
i'll be working to support them over the
coming days to do just that okay let's
talk rwanda and pretty patel of course
making it pretty clear she wants to push
ahead uh with the policy of sending
asylum seekers to
rwanda
after it was blocked in the courts when
do you hope the first plane to take off
well i can't comment on those
operational specifics of when that plane
might take off but we are talking about
a matter of weeks and we've been
consistently clear that we need to
deliver on this policy objective we
can't continue to have people making
perilous journeys across the channel
facilitated by evil criminal gangs
undercutting of course people coming via
safe and legal means let's come in there
and we have other states and legal means
if you're not from ukraine or
afghanistan where there are clear uh
routes to the uk
how do you claim asylum because if you
look at the government's advice um
you know that it says that you should
apply for asylum when you arrive in the
uk but it also says your claim
effectively won't be considered if
you've traveled to the uk through a safe
third country i mean it's basically
impossible to claim asylum legally isn't
it well the point is that what we do is
we respond to global crises as they
emerge and we have bespoke schemes that
are in place to provide the support that
we want to give and i think we have a
proud tradition so if you're not from if
you're not from ukraine and you're not
from afghanistan what is the safe and
legal route for you to claim asylum in
the uk well there's further examples
look at for example the response to the
hong kong b o situation look at the
response to the syria crisis where we
accommodate that it's going to be a
deterrent for the people in france
currently when there isn't another route
for them to claim all of those people
sophia leaving what are fundamentally
safe countries to make perilous journeys
the idea that
one of the things we do for example is
we work with the unhcr in refugee camps
in areas around the world to provide
resettlement opportunities for people
obviously the unhcr do have a lot of
experience in handling those cases in
identifying particular vulnerabilities
where we can make the biggest impact in
terms of our help i think that's the
right approach so that in response to
individual crises we make the best
possible schemes that are as generous as
possible we've seen that in response to
ukraine in recent weeks and the
generosity of the british people but i
also think if we can help the most
vulnerable people on the face of the
planet that's precisely what we should
do
i just want to read the uk government's
current travel advice to rwanda
it says homosexual sexuality isn't
illegal in rwanda but it remains frowned
on by many lgbt individuals can
experience discrimination and abuse
including from local authorities there
are no specific anti-discrimination laws
that protect lgbt individuals are you
comfortable at sending people to a
country where
according to your own advice they can
experience discrimination and abuse
including from local authorities well
actually there's a fundamental principle
that cuts through the
rwandan constitution that deals with
anti-discrimination and you mentioned
the travel advice from the fcdo but
we've also had conducted a comprehensive
country report on rwanda that deals with
all of these matters that work is
carried out by a reputable team that
actually the courts have regularly
commended the quality of the work that
is done as being authoritative in terms
of those country by country reports and
it's also just worth pointing out that
the unhcr placed people in rwanda for
the purposes of providing sanctuary
which i think gives quite a strong
indication about how they feel about
people being safe in fact there's
representatives of the unhcr who are on
the record saying rwanda is a safe
environment for refugees but of course
in the end the fundamental principle
that we work through in this policy is
that people will only be relocated if it
is safe and appropriate for them it's
right that we take case by case
decisions taking proper account of
people's circumstances uh just finally
there's been some frustration from some
of your colleagues about the ruling by
the european court of human rights do
you think it's time to look at um
pulling out
so the prime minister said that we will
rule nothing out and that we're gonna
have to look at this because we've got
to deliver on this policy we've made a
commitment we're determined to deliver
on this and i would argue that there's
lives at stake if we don't follow
through
you're leaving the door open but the
difficulty we've got at the moment is
obviously the european court of human
rights has handed down a ruling but we
haven't been even provided with the
detail of that ruling and the
underpinning rationale behind it so when
i left the office earlier all it's
saying my understanding is that you
should just wait until the the actual
judgment which is in july i don't think
it's unreasonable for us as ministers to
want to see
all of that information properly
presented and in full so that we can
make judgments about what is appropriate
in terms of next steps but the prime
minister said that we don't rule out
having to change our domestic law for
example if that's what's necessary in
order to facilitate this the thing is if
we don't we'll just continue to have
these criminal gangs exploiting people
taking their money all the risk to life
we've lost 27 lives in the channel in
november 39 people in the back of a
lorry in grazing essex a few years ago
that is what keeps me awake at night
frankly as the illegal migration
minister we've got to get to grips with
it failure is simply not an option okay
thank you very much for being on the
program uh tom perez love